Paul Rudd is a friend of yours you guys
have worked together and yeah he was
zero this guy he's next to me the same
best but yeah Paul read Paul Rudd third
best guy he was uh he was here recently
and he said that he tried to play he's
tried to play urinal pranks on you yeah
and when what he goes and he's using a
urinal if he knows that you're gonna
also be coming to the bathroom he loves
to play pranks and do funny things with
the urinal what is he talking about what
kind of things well free mention one
which was dropping lowering his pants
all the way when he uses a year yeah
like he's it like he's a ten year old
boy right and it also it's not that he
knows I'm gonna come in he hopes I'm
gonna come in but he doesn't know right
anyone could come in he does it at
airports
it was while we were on he I Love You
Man pressed to her yeah I know a lot of
time together and going to a lot of
airports so he would have three pranks
sometimes I'd walk it into a bathroom
and he would be standing there amongst
other grown men with his pants and
underwear down to his ankles like a
little boy that's insane around
strangers around strangers
then also he's Paul Rudd yeah noticeable
yeah yeah isn't leibold about it and
then he does another one where he slowly
starts taking steps backward as he's
using the urinal no eventually he's very
quite far away he's four he's four
hundred feet away yeah yeah and then
sometimes we're at the urinal together
and there's other people around he'll
just go like this
nice penis
[Applause]
it's gonna cause a problem don't you
think it's pretty close okay you should
stop doing that yeah all right I have
proof all right
when the guy's telling you you got a
nice penis you go over with it yeah you
don't deny you say yes there was a story
you're just saying well you're at the
you're at the best angle if I turn this
way hey thanks for watching please
subscribe to my youtube channel so they
will stop making me shoot these videos
please